the war in ukraine has come just as the
world is being threatened by a global
food supply crisis
among the worst affected countries
somalia where drought and crop failure
threaten a new famine streams of people
coming in still across you know the
dusty terrain they're carrying all their
possessions on their back they've got
kids and animals in tow they are fleeing
from the worst drought-affected areas
obviously there are a number of factors
leading to this crisis but how much is
ukraine's war
playing a role in this food prices were
already soaring due to livestock deaths
due to serial crop failures but the big
concern though is that ukraine is just
going to exacerbate this make it so much
worse the war in ukraine threatens to
turn crisis into catastrophe for
hundreds of millions globally who depend
on its grain last year its grain exports
fed 400 million people worldwide as we
filmed in ukraine last month millions of
tons are now trapped in the country it's
port stand idle
the world was already facing a food
supply crisis but russia's invasion of
ukraine is making it much much worse
with all these ukrainian ports on the
black sea now blocked the un is warning
that 47 million more people will face
acute hunger across the world if the war
goes on the latest u.n hunger report is
added afghanistan and somalia to its
list of the highest alert countries
described as facing catastrophic
conditions they're marked in red on this
map those with deteriorating conditions
include all of these countries in orange
including the democratic republic of the
congo sudan syria and kenya has just
been added to the list because of its
dependence on grain imports these
countries in yellow like sri lanka
zimbabwe angola lebanon are described as
areas of concern ukraine itself has now
been added to that list for the first
time because of what it's going through
at the hands of russia's invasion
but russia isn't bowing to mounting
international criticism let's be honest
the kremlin
is using food supplies
a stealth missile against developing
countries
russia isn't just blockading ukraine's
ports it's accused of stealing its grain
too caught on satellite loading it into
ships and the ports it's occupied
places like kenya that depend on grain
imports face soaring food prices on top
of drought and crop failure the mass
suffering caused by the war in ukraine
is being exported far beyond its borders
dominic waghorn sky news